in this video you will learn the
most important thing about the topic is scale
this is the third video on the
topic of questionnaires if you like you can
read the content in our book questionnaires
made easy
you can find the link in the video description
we start with the most important question
why do we need a link at all
karla let's assume you have
formulated your hypothesis in which a not
directly measurable variable, a so
-called latent variable,
patent variables are, for example,
physical well-being and environmental awareness
why are these variables not directly
measurable of course you could  in your
questionnaire simply ask how high is
your environmental awareness only with this
one question you will
be able to measure environmental awareness very difficult or only very imprecisely because environmental awareness consists of
several dimensions the first
person thinks I am in an
animal protection association and take care of
n  suffering animals and ticks very high
but on the other hand makes a long-distance trip by plane
three times a year
the next person thinks
well my awareness of the environment is
very high i know that people actually
separate waste and not by car all the
time  should drive there
my awareness of the environment is high
but i don’t stick to it this
person then high or low so of course you
can just
ask this single question to measure
environmental awareness the
answers won’t
be able to do much about it but latent
variables  how
to be able to adequately measure environmental awareness
one now uses a scale a scale is a group
of questions eg question 1 2 3 and 4 with the
answer options of true that
is not true these questions
together enable you to measure a latent variable
by using several  questions
use a measurement more accurate such
a scale is also called a multit  herm
scale refers to the most well-known scale
is the scale on the left kader
is a method with which
personal attitudes can
be measured the league consists of
several questions so-called items items
are statements that can record the degree of
agreement or service of the respondents
i.e. indicate on a multi-level answer scale
how much you disagree or
agree with a statement a four
or five-level rating is usually used but
a middle category makes sense or
not can not be said in general terms
in some cases it makes sense for the
respondents to give a neutral  have medium category
available so as not
to be pushed in one direction by law there
is a risk that many respondents
will simply choose the medium category
, which can make their results less
meaningful the next
question is how do i get to the
right questions i think the
just ask  That's not a
good idea, because in this case
you would first have to carefully check whether your questions
really measure the latent variable correctly.
The clean way is to
research literature and scales
and find out whether there are
already validated questions with which
you can eat your variables  this is
the easiest way to start
researching literature and scales
we just start quick and
dirty and just google
environmental awareness questionnaires and the
first result looks pretty
promising general
environmental awareness it is an open access
repository for social  - and
behavioral science
survey instruments so let's
just click on it and the
overview we'll see a summary the scale
captures general environmental
awareness environmental awareness as a general belief or world view the assessment
of the construct is based on a
rational choice model and so on and
so on so that sounds
good now let's just click on
instruments and lo and behold here we find
items we use to
query general environmental awareness now
you only need to copy these questions into the
questionnaire and cite the source
cleanly in your thesis
you have
an idea of ​​what it looks like in a questionnaire
let's just create a
question block with data tab we go to
online survey click on new question
and simply select from forest table
matrix
now let's just copy the questions
here as an example  the first
three are enough
and the ratings are saved
in a finished question what does it look like
so now it looks like your questionnaire and
lets fill it out we assume
that you have received enough
responses and a survey is finished what do
you do  Now with the answers, let's look at each
other so that we don't have too much
text, let's take e  just
this example again the
participants has a survey only
for questions 1 to 4 something from
applies that does not apply marked with a cross now
you can export the finished survey to
excel or datatec then
in each row there is one respondent and
in the  split the four questions the first
person ticked question 12 for
question 2 1 for question 33 and for question 42
now you want to use these four questions to
measure your latent variable
metric scania is often assumed in practice
strictly speaking
the answers are on a  Scale originally
scaled because the distances between the
answers are
probably not
perceived as equal by the survey participants,
the most common way is that you form
a so-called mean
value index for this you simply calculate the mean value of
each series so that you now have an
assessment led to a variable you
can too  easily with data tab
den Mittel  create a value index here earlier
simply copy your data in this
table and click on
transform data now you click on index
creation and like now questions 1 to 4 from
then click on average index and
enter the name for your new variable done and a new variable
has been created  now it can still check
and your question, simply put, is really
a latent variable or
not you can do this with the korbacher feel free to
watch my video
otherwise it will continue with the
next video you will find out how you with
data online your question where  can create
and send to the same